there does appear to be some change on
the horizon with the Clark County School
Board there's two incumbents with their
seats on the line this morning Mary Jane
beliesza is at CCSD to talk a little bit
more about this and it can be very
contentious on CCSD School Board
yeah John and Heather good morning to
you and you guys are absolutely correct
a change in staff on the way for the
Clark County School District and voters
got a chance to set the course for the
country's fifth largest school district
on Tuesday there are three board seats
up for grabs and now in District D it's
president Irene Cepeda running against
Brenda Zamora cepedo was elected to the
board in 2018 and took over as president
earlier this year after serving as vice
president meanwhile in District F
trustee Daniel Ford is running against
Irene Bustamante Adams trustee Linda
Cavazos and former Eureka County school
superintendent Greg Wyman are competing
for the district G seat this election
follows years of turmoil the school
district has also spent thousands of
dollars for training and Retreat to try
and get along on taxpayers dime now
despite the training fighting at school
board meetings and social media
continued so far unofficial results show
Cepeda and Ford may be losing their seat
as Cavazos may be keeping hers School
races are nonpartisan so any candidate
winning a majority of the vote will win
election to the board now again as a
reminder these are unofficial results it
may take time to get the certified
results in just a few days reporting
live from the school district on Sahara
in Decatur Mary June bellissa 8 News Now